♪ ♪
>> Tucker: BECAUSE ABSOLUTELY
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE IN THE YEAR
2020, THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
ANDREW CUOMO IS COMING OUT WITH
THE NEW BOOK "BRAGGING" ABOUT
HOW HE RESPONDED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
JOINING US NOW IS JANICE DEAN, A
SENIOR METEOROLOGIST HERE AT
FOX NEWS.
SADLY, HER IN-LAWS DIED IN
NURSING HOMES IN NEW YORK STATE
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES
ANDREW CUOMO BACK.
WE SHOULD ALSO SAY JANICE DEAN
IS ONE OF THE MOST HONEST PEOPLE
WE KNOW AND THEREFORE ONE OF OUR
FAVORITE GUESTS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
I’M GOING TO THROW IT TO YOU,
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THIS
BOOK?
>> I COULDN’T BELIEVE IT WHEN I
FOUND OUT JUST A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO THAT HE HAD TIME TO
WRITE A BOOK IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
I MEAN, WHAT GOVERNOR WOULD HAVE
TIME TO DO THAT?
IT’S INCREDIBLE.
I ACTUALLY THOUGHT IT WAS A
SATIRE WHEN I SAW HE WAS WRITING
A BOOK ABOUT HIS LEADERSHIP,
TAKING A VICTORY LAB FOR
PLANNING THE CURVE, THE CURVE
THAT HAS MY IN LAWS ON IT.
HE HAS LOST MORE PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK FROM CORONAVIRUS ON HIS
WATCH THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
OVER THE 300,000 PEOPLE HAVE
DIED, INCLUDING MY IN-LAWS.
WE STILL DON’T HAVE THE ACTUAL
TOTAL NUMBER OF DEATHS FROM
SENIORS GETTING COVID AND THEIR
ASSISTANT LIVING FACILITIES OR
THEIR ELDERCARE FACILITIES
BECAUSE HIS NURSING HOME
REPRESENTATIVE, HIS HEALTH
COMMISSIONER WILL NOT GIVE US
THE ACCURATE TOTALS OF THOSE
THAT DIED IN HOSPITALS, LIKE MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW.
THERE’S ALL THESE UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE ABOUT HIS
LEADERSHIP THAT HE HAS NOT
ANSWERED IN HIS SO-CALLED BOOK.
>> Tucker: DID YOU EXPECT HIM
TO APOLOGIZE?
SINCE YOUR QUESTION.
>> I’M NOT SURE.
UP UNTIL THIS POINT, HE HASN’T
APOLOGIZED.
I THINK IN THE VERY BEGINNING,
TUCKER, IF HE HAD TAKEN SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT I WAS
TRYING TO SAVE SOME OF THE
HOSPITAL BEDS FOR THE PATIENTS
THAT WE NEEDED, AND THAT’S WHY I
MADE THAT MISTAKE OF PUTTING
COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS INTO
NURSING HOMES FOR 46 DAYS, BY
THE WAY.
IF HE HAD DONE THAT IN THE VERY
BEGINNING BUT HE NEVER HAS AND
BY THE WAY, HE’S BLAMED EVERYONE
ELSE EXCEPT THE PERSON THAT
SIGNED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER,
ANDREW CUOMO.
IT WAS IN EFFECT FOR 46 DAYS.
HE IS BLAMED GOD AND
MOTHER NATURE AND THE PRESIDENT
AND THE CDC AND
"THE NEW YORK POST" AND
FOX NEWS, HE BLAMED EVERYONE
EXCEPT THE PERSON THAT SIGNED
THE MANDATE, THE ORDER PUTTING
THOSE COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS
INTO NURSING HOMES.
THAT’S WHAT GETS MY BLOOD
BOILING.
HE STILL REFUSES TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
THE OTHER DAY IN AN INTERVIEW HE
ACTUALLY SAID WE DIDN’T NEED TO
PUT COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS INTO
NURSING HOMES AND I SCREAMED.
IT JUST MAKES OUR GRIEF EVEN
WORSE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I COULDN’T AGREE
MORE.
WE’VE MADE MISTAKES ON THIS SHOW
BUT YOU KNOW A MAN’S CHARACTER
BY THEIR REACTION NEXT.
PEOPLE WHO BLAME OTHERS AND
DON’T APOLOGIZE FOR THEIR
MISTAKES, IT’S JUST THE LOWEST
AND I’M SORRY YOU HAD TO SUFFER